au menu ce midi pour ce vétérinaire qui
travaillent à deux pas ces repas maurice
1 au drive qui vient d'être installé au
restaurant lille où coco super merci
beaucoup
après moi quand je finirai de bosser
parce que c'est rigolo jusqu'à deux ans
et demi je venais souvent manger ici
quand j'avais pas le temps et là le fait
qu'ils rouvrent avait prononcé quand
même très très pratique
parce que
des fois on n'a pas le temps je voyais
l'ingénieur jean je devais avoir dix
minutes pour manger ça me permet d'avoir
quelque chose à proximité et en plus ce
qui est bon parce que c'est vrai que
c'est toujours bon ici après plusieurs
semaines de fermeture
impossible pour cette gérante de par
ouvrir son restaurant avant d'organiser
des ventes à emporter
elle ad'abord livrer des repas au
personnel soignant de l'hôpital privé de
l'ouest parisien à trappes et dans
certains commissariats
quand je vois le le président a annoncé
que le confinement à rallonger le camion
je dis là c'est pas possible il faudra
que je fais quelque chose parce que je
veux vous dire une chose c'est vrai dans
la restauration
ça sort mais ça rend pas voilà le
problème c'est que il ya tout à payer
alors vous voyez le jeudi là ça commence
à m'inquiéter
et là je dis oui je le sais parce que
j'ai la licence pour le drive et c'est
que j'ai fait je dis je met en place le
drive pour essayer de combler les pertes
financières
la gérante est dans l'obligation
d'ouvrir son restaurant 7 jours sur 7
avec une carte réduite et un prix fixe
elle reçoit une trentaine de clients les
jours les plus influents je trouve que
dans la semaine c'est calme
et quand même je veux vous dire que je
fais si je fais une dizaine de plats bon
ça paye sapm électricité s'appelle
hausse appel
les téléphones tout ce qui est l'objet
j'ai pas le choix sinon mais on met la
clé sous la porte comme toutes mes
collègues comme on va dire le coiffeuse
qu'on va tout les gens qui ont des
petits commerces pas comme beaucoup de
restaurateurs et le dit yann piat attend
à présent les nouvelles annonces de
l'état concernant la réouverture des
commerces